now news is moving fast on the
coronavirus front you've heard some of
it earlier today but even tonight things
are changing and the government's
response to it we're gonna give you the
latest first now we have this 2.1 2.2
trillion dollar relief package that both
parties it seems like finally agreed on
today this 2.2 trillion dollar
legislative package is bigger than
anything I believed ever passed in
Congress perhaps relatively speaking if
you go back look during the FDR New Deal
days there was something that if you
time value it you could say it was
bigger I don't know but this is
certainly in terms of dollars by far and
away the biggest ever ever done and well
of course that sent a lot of
conservatives just like gasping when
they heard that but we knew it was
coming and most of us did understand
that something needed to be done to help
American workers and businesses there's
a lot though at the same time not to
like in this package now check this out
Nancy Pelosi is still holding out for
this provision that would basically gut
any state voter ID requirements I kid
you not there's all sorts of stuff the
ballot harvesting this is a nightmare
so I thinking about this I guess they're
watching old Joe's campaign stumbles so
the whole thing is really starting to
look like a weekend at Biden's as I said
a few weeks ago and another concern that
the federal unemployment benefits we
want people to get help but will last 39
weeks in other words through the end of
2020 god help us if this shutdown goes
on that long or any were approaching
that long so when you add up the state
unemployment benefits with the federal
benefits the average weekly unemployment
check will be about nine hundred and
seventy two dollars which again when you
do the math exceeds the median weekly
earnings of American workers from
quarter four of last year meanwhile the
dire tone seemed to change today at the
New York governor's kovat 19 briefing
comme Cuomo seemed to let up
little bit on the blame game it's
something that our team is working on
with the White House team and I want to
thank the president for his cooperation
and his team for their cooperation well
that was good to hear and you guys New
York still accounts for about 60% of
nuke ovid cases in the u.s. there is
more room for optimism it actually
appears that the rate of
hospitalizations is slowing remember the
big concern always has been a potential
collapse of the healthcare system this
past Sunday
the projection was that hospitalizations
were doubling every two days okay
on Monday the number suggested that the
hospitalizations were doubling every
three point four days on Tuesday the
projections suggested that the
hospitalizations were doubling every
four point seven days now that is almost
too good to be true the arrows are
headed in the right direction
and that is always better than the
arrows headed in the wrong direction
I'll say in the number of new infections
in New York is starting to show some
signs of good news as well on Monday the
state reported an increase of five
thousand seven hundred and seven on
Tuesday it went up four thousand seven
hundred and ninety that's nearly a
thousand person decrease in the rate of
increase this kind of gets confusing but
in today it went up five thousand one
hundred and forty six but that's still
down from two days ago you see those
trends now if that trend does hold it's
really good news about when this
nightmare actually Peaks and then we
start seeing light at the end of the
tunnel
let's hope but fear is powerful we all
know that and in this case it's
understandable given what we've seen
around the world specially in places
like Italy but fear alone should not
drive policy facts and reliable updated
data should inform all of our
projections dr. Burks from the
coronavirus task force seemed to be
alluding to that today we're really
dealing with the here and now why we're
planning for the future and I think the
numbers that have been put out there
are actually very frightening to people
but I can tell you if you go back and
look at Wuhan and who Bay and all of
these provinces when they talk about
60,000 people being infected even if you
said oh right well there's asymptomatic
sand all of that so you get to 600,000
people out of 80 million that is nowhere
close to the numbers that you see people
putting out there I think it is
frightened the American people
that's perspective we need that
perspective as scary as this seems and
finally new drug therapies are being
tested and used including one used even
to treat gout and antibodies tests may
tell us who already has immunity to this
virus may have gotten it not had a big
strong reaction to it already developing
those important immunities that'll also
help us prepare better for the future
and around the world countries are
taking different approaches India has a
total lockdown now and after Italy's
horrific experience and you kind of
can't blame people extreme social
distancing it's affected in the UK in
Spain but Sweden and Denmark have
rejected the total lockdown approach and
they're getting some grief for it but
are not seeing a greater rate of
infection than some of their European
counterparts that's really interesting
only time will tell which approach was
right and which one might have been
going a little too extreme but for us
we're ending day 10 of the first 15 days
and how much longer can we anticipate
this shutdown lasting